[MUSIC PLAY]
AARON MARSHALL: I'm part of a small percentage
people in the world who can literally work from anywhere.
And it's freedom for me.
One of my family values ​​is that we think
life is about living fantastic stories.
And so to get to Cape Town, start this business,
And to live like that, we think is a fantastic story.
The possibilities here are endless.
We love it.
Over is a simple application to add text to photos.
You can rotate the text, change the color,
really fit in with customization.
We offer hundreds of fonts.
And we constantly upload new fonts
you can unlock.
We also have artwork, some of which are exclusive.
The decision for us to go to Android was obvious.
80% of the global market is currently using Android.
And we were really passionate about helping people
to be creative, and that was an easy way
to get many more people.
JONATHAN ORFORD: It's everywhere.
It is growing very, very fast.
And we want to be part of it.
The high-level and low-level devices
support everyone Over, which is great for us.
When we decided to develop the Android app,
I already had two developers in mind.
They had Java experience, but very limited Android
experience.
They were able to get to know much, very quickly,
and we could start writing code within days.
JOHAN NELL: I joined Over with no previous Android experience.
And I and Herko and I could get a working prototype
to Aaron within the first week.
HERKO LATEGAN: My experience
About to develop Android was really fast.
It took us two months.
And originally our product manager
thought it would take a lot longer.
And I think the biggest advantage of working on Android
is that the tools are incredible.
You have Android Studio.
And you have all this documentation
Immediately at your disposal, making it easy for us.
JONATHAN ORFORD: We offer our program
to as many countries as we possibly can
and therefore we need to adjust the prices.
And some countries want rounded prices, some not.
We have full control over our pricing with Google Play
Developer.
This is one place where I can go and see everything.
I can look at statistics.
I can look at my deployments.
I can see ratings and reviews.
This is brilliant.
And it's all in one place and very, very easy to use.
AARON MARSHALL: I love the Google Play experience.
I can even talk to the customers in the reviews.
And that customer commitment is extremely valuable.
If you don't know what they think,
if you can't interact and talk and ask questions,
It's hard to work out what is valuable.
And to drive value to customers
what a company and a new business is all about.
JOHAN NELL: I remember the first day we started,
just look at the analyzes and see how people
the program starts and uses it
and then moving on to the social networking services
and to see these artwork, these pictures that people
create with codes we wrote.
The creativity that inspires it makes your mouth hang.
It was really exciting.
AARON MARSHALL: All around we have a mantra.
We always say: go big and go home.
We don't think you should sacrifice your family
to acquire wealth or create value or the world
to change.
What helps it to have all those things
if you do not have a family for that success
to share?
So for us success is twofold.
We want to go big, and we want to go home.